welcome to this blitz game okay yeah
playing very all very all from Canada
what do we get the realities do
something different the Schliemann or
yanush gambit leading to interesting
claim one of the rare completely um
completely sound gambits really for
black they're really not many most black
gambits are really really not good and
the yen ish is one of the very few that
that is really really good opening or
Schliemann ads specifically this this
naming convention is a bit tricky some
people say Schliemann some some say
yanush the f5 a variation interesting
interesting way how he played it it's
not very common to put the knight on c3
quite often this is not good due to the
bishop before pin but he had already
castle so this wasn't this wasn't really
a problem
yeah the good thing about this line with
d3 and the capture is that black has a
very simple development the f file is
open though its prizes me okay let's
let's do it check hmm d5 why isn't d525
winning a piece
and the Queen hangs with check so you
cannot play any fancy stuff like 95 I
mean even if it wasn't a check
now I was one of those two quick moves
Bishop c4 check right resigns yeah just
just the bees yeah f5 is this pretty a
pretty decent I mean yeah white normally
chooses d3 or 93 I personally think that
93 is a bit more problematic an
important point is that the move d4
really isn't any good this line is
basically a check blundering this pawn
d3 or 93 and 93 and then black can take
Knight f6 it's very active with F porn
quickly traded against the upon the only
drawback of this line is that there are
a couple of continuations where why does
some winning the e5 pawn form well black
has decent compensation but it often is
a compensation that it's just about
enough to just hold it yeah you can
really hard time hard time to play for
win sometimes but in general this is not
a bad opening the sriman organische
gambit okay thanks for watching